we're here to talk about CSS and
specifically modern CSS we're talking
about flexbox CSS grids pseudo elements
specifically before and after elements
because I find that those are the most
useful things I use this all the time
transitions and animations blend modes
and texture typography so the benefits
of using these tools basically that you
can speed up your site if you're using
more modern CSS it means you have to
write less code which also means that
it's easier you can save yourself some
time writing code and when you write one
line of CSS and it's magic you get that
great job satisfaction of I'm a wizard
so when we start using some of these new
tools it's really important to think
about browser support and what your
clients need for their websites or if
you are a non-profit or a higher ed
institution what you need for your own
site to make sure that you're serving
your visitors to your site because if
you have people coming in from ie9 and
that's your primary target audience
unfortunately a lot of these are gonna
not perform as well in those older
browsers but there are some fall backs
that we can talk about to give the
better display to people who are coming
in on newer browsers and give they give
you that modern edge while still
providing content to the people in those
older browsers so in order to do this we
need to be organized we need to make
sure that we're covering our bases so
testing is really important every time
you try one of these tools out I highly
encourage you to pull open browser stack
or a virtual machine or even an actual
physical device to see how it's
performed
in that environment to make sure that
it's doing what you want because
sometimes they're tricky little bits at
the end that you know it'll look great
in Chrome but if you open up in Mobile
Safari you might run into some issues so
just constantly doing those little
checks will save you from a huge
headache at the end of the product cycle
and right when you're trying to launch
you're not trying to fix all of those
problems at once additionally you might
need to change the language in your
proposals if you're an agency you might
have language in your proposals that
talks about browser support or you might
not I find that it's very handy to have
it in there because that way you can
have that conversation upfront and there
are no surprises later on this is really
key don't have surprises on your
websites so what we've done is we
support two versions back of the most
recent browsers which means that we
support I 11 and edge as well as the
last two versions of Chrome Safari and
Firefox so your language can vary
depending on the the kind of people that
you're working with but this is also
something that can be negotiated in that
contracting phase and then finally you
need to make sure that your team's on
board if you are trying to use textured
typography for example and you're a
designer and you have this beautiful SVG
rendering but it doesn't show up then
your design might have some issues so
making sure that you know where the
graceful degradation is going to happen
and so that you're everybody on your
team knows that we don't have to have
those awkward conversations later on
all right so here's what you all came
here for it's the actual code and how
you use things so first up I'm gonna
talk about flexbox this is actually my
favorite piece that's why I put it first
flex box is incredibly powerful and you
don't have to write very much if you
don't want to flex box is really useful
when you need to have things essentially
float next to each other but you don't
want to have to write floats and wits
and worry about how tall each item is
it's basically gonna do all the thinking
for you this is also useful if you have
like a card kind of design where you
need things to be equal Heights
and you don't want to write JavaScript
you know javascript is loading later on
then CSS and CSS can perform better for
you so why do it in JavaScript if you
can do it and CSS it's a little quicker
and then also you can do some things
with flexbox that are a little tricky
you can change the Dom order with Flex
box now this is a little bit tricky you
have to be careful that you're not
moving content around in a way that will
fool screen readers so I find that this
is most useful when I'm moving images
around if I'm moving an image to be
before a heading or after a heading say
when I'm transitioning from mobile to
desktop so just be careful about how
you're rearranging that content but
otherwise it's really powerful so we
have an example here this is from the
national parks website national parks at
work and this site was built two years
ago now but at the time flex box had
just come out and so this is actually a
mixture of flex box and floats and I
used flex box to get the height of the
card which is not totally apparent on
this screen to match the bottom edge
even though the the titles are varying
lengths
and then likewise on find your part calm
these bottom three buttons plan your
visit found my Park and share on
Facebook
these have flexbox applied so that as
you're resizing your screen as soon as
there's not enough room for that text to
fit anymore it's gonna break that third
button down into that next line just
like that and if you're on a big screen
like say one of the massive Mac monitors
or if you have an ultra-wide then
they'll all sit next to each other and
all you had to do is apply one line of
CSS you say display flex it's amazing so
you can see here I'm sitting next to
each other so the key here is to apply
the style to the parent elements you
will have some adjustments that you can
do on the individual items but the the
really key point is the parent so we're
talking like if you have a list of
elements you would apply the display
flex to the unordered list element not
to the Li so these are all of your
options with Flex box like I said
display flex is all you really need
that's going to get you started as you
continue to develop it's key to add
these in incrementally because if you do
it all at once without really knowing
what each item does you know you might
get ahead of yourself or get overwhelmed
so I encourage you to try this you know
spend 20 minutes do one piece spend
another five minutes or another piece
you know gradually add things and
that'll make it so that you're not going
crazy so flex wrap is really powerful I
want to talk about that one in specific
because this is what I find myself
adjusting most often if you have items
that
don't want to flow to a second row
you'll apply nowrap and that will force
them to all stick into one a row no
matter what but if you want them to wrap
like say you're doing a staff listing
page or a listing a blog post that kind
of thing you can set it to wrap and
that's pretty straightforward the other
piece here is flex direction so I've
been talking about row a lot which is a
pretty typical use case but you can also
do column which is incredibly powerful I
haven't found a lot of use cases for it
to be honest but if you do let me know
tweet at me so then you can perform
overrides on those internal elements so
if you have a property on the parent
that you want to apply to all of the
elements inside and there's one special
case there's one item you always need
the first item to be bigger than the
others for example you can set that with
one of these overrides on the individual
item so alignment and grow and shrink
all of those can be overridden here so
alignment basically has to do with where
it vertically lines up with the siblings
next to it flex grow and shrink that
allows it to expand and contract based
off of ratio integers so if you set Flex
grow to one on one list item that will
expand larger than the rest and for
example if you wanted to have a very
specific ratio you could set one item
would be Flex grow two and another item
to be Flex grow one and the first item
would always be double the second one
make sense
it's easy right guys alright so here's
the tricky part when not to use so there
are always caveats so if you need
specific widths at specific breakpoints
if you have a very pixel perfect kind of
design
I wouldn't recommend using flexbox that
said maybe you can have a conversation
with your design team or with your
client about having a little flexibility
there because it'll perform better
across all devices you won't have to
write as much code it'll save you time
which saves them money it all stacks up
to beautiful things and then again just
talking about adjusting the order of the
elements so if you set an item to be
Flex order one and another item be Flex
order two it doesn't actually matter
what order they're they're printing out
originally they're gonna go one and then
two so if you do that and you move a
button for example and someone is using
their keyboard to navigate and they're
tabbing through they're going to hit
that content in the wrong order from
what you're intending from the visual
side and we want that experience to be
consistent for all of our users so it's
very important to be careful about what
you're moving around and when and then
browser fullbacks
alright so this comes from can I use
comm this is a great website that will
give you all of the issues that might
still exist with certain browsers so
it's a very long list but it's not
actually all that bad
these are all very specific use cases
that will maybe cause a little hang-ups
so example like flexbox in button
elements in Firefox 51 and below I think
we're now on like 80 something so there
are a few of these that aren't that big
of a deal but again testing is what's
going to do you the most favors here
um for all of the tools in this deck
essentially if you're in IE 11 or up
you're gonna be in pretty good shape
ie is always gonna have more problems
than other browsers in some cases
because they got a little ahead of
themselves but you know they were trying
to be ambitious it's cool so next up we
have CSS grids so originally I called
this Pinterest II layouts but that's not
entirely accurate
Pinterest e layouts are more like
vertical flexbox I guess in that you can
set a column and then if it wraps it
goes to a second column and then a third
column and then a fourth home but CSS
grids instead of working in one
dimension they're working in two so
you're setting things both based off of
vertical and horizontal positioning it's
quite a bit like using absolute
positioning except CSS grids are more
responsive so with CSS grids you can do
something like this I did not use CSS
grids for this because this this is that
older site but if I were to rebuild this
I would use CSS grids because it would
be a lot less code than what I used
originally this is a lot of absolute
positioning and setting Heights and
matching Heights and making sure that my
images are the right dimensions and my
media styles it's craziness but what we
could have done here is set up a four
column by four row grid and that would
have solved all of these problems
so essentially newspaper layouts or
again reordering elements in the Dom
visually or if you would use absolute
positioning or JavaScript to achieve
this kind of solution where you're
calculating the height of something and
making the height of something else
with JavaScript please don't do that
so the way that we do this is to set up
our columns on the parent element again
just like with Flex box we're setting up
all these rules on the parent element
the wrapper around all of these items
that we want to position so you you can
use names for these columns it's really
helpful so on the grid container we're
just gonna set display grid and that's
gonna get you going but then we need to
get our columns and rows set up to make
sure that we have the the actual amount
of columns and that they're the right
widths for us so the way that CSS grid
keeps track of these columns is actually
by the grid lines and not by the grid
columns themselves so if you want to
place an item within the first column
you would actually place it based off of
the first grid line and if you want it
to go in the second column you would
place it off of that second grid line
but you can think about it and in terms
of regions within the grid as opposed to
the lines themselves which I've
demonstrated in the next slide
so at the bottom here we've got an
individual item where we're setting up
where it starts and where it ends and
you can do that on any element in your
grid and when you have multiple items
that you're setting in a grid they don't
actually know where each other live or
are or move so you could set two items
to be right on top of each other so
that's that's kind of what I'm talking
about with the absolute positioning
effects where it just kind of does what
you tell it to and isn't very smart
about it so it's incredibly powerful and
but use with caution so
here in our grid
we're actually naming our regions now so
once we have our grid set up we can name
what these areas are just say okay I
have this 16 column grid but actually
it's only 4 and 12 and I have a sidebar
in a main body region so I don't
actually need all of this all the time
so what you can do is you can say okay
from the in the first column that's
going to be a and then in the second and
third columns that's going to be B and
the way that CSS knows that you're
naming that entire region B is that you
align your naming with your grid
specifications so if we have three
columns we've got the 150 pixel wide
setting here for each of the columns and
we also have three named declarations
but when you want to play something
within those regions you can actually
just say grid area and then name so if I
were using this on a site for example
instead of a I would say sidebar and
instead of B I'd say main and then main
again and so item one would be in grid
area sidebar and item two would be in
grid area main makes a lot easier to
remember so why not to use this when
simple floats are gonna do this for you
or inline-block or if you don't need the
two dimensional effect to happen if you
don't need to play something further
down on the page of further up on the
page you can achieve this same effect
with flexbox so this is really powerful
when you have multiple columns and rows
of sibling elements but if it's just got
to be in columns or just got to be in
rows
then use flexbox and this list for
browser limitations is actually a lot
shorter so this one is a little trickier
though like I said earlier Microsoft got
very ambitious and before any of the
other browsers adopted CSS grids
Microsoft was like hey let's do this and
they're naming conventions are different
if you try to set up your grid lines in
the same way in Microsoft for Internet
Explorer you're gonna get all sorts of
wonky placement so if you use an
automatic prefix ur for example this is
gonna run into some problems for you so
I recommend turning off things like
autoprefixer for CSS grid in particular
and manually coding that or using floats
as your fallback using a class from say
it like moderniser javascript is not
evil I love JavaScript but I like to use
it as a utility for those kinds of
fallback situations so next up we have
pseudo elements so this is before and
after elements these are incredibly
powerful essentially what you can do
with these is you can place any content
or treat it like a div without having to
modify your actual Dom without having to
write extra twig functions to print out
an extra div over here and without
having to you know adjust your fields to
do this for you so the really helpful
thing here is when you're doing icon
work or if you have other responsive
ornaments that you need to place things
that don't have content in them they're
they're purely visual ornamentation you
don't want to use this for content
because we want to make sure that people
using screen readers have access to this
content if you put content in a before
after element it's not going to be read
so this is an example of a before
element that's just acting basically
like a div and the way that you do this
is to add this before syntax and I've
seen it both ways the single colon and
double it works both ways I haven't
actually had a problem so I used the
shorter one again fewer clicks I'm a
lazy developer so if you leave your
content declaration this is the most
important piece this is what's gonna
actually give you your pseudo element
content you can place either an icon
reference in here for your font file or
you can leave it empty and just put some
quotes in there and it'll give you
essentially an empty div without
actually having a div it's just a pseudo
element so in your inspector what you'll
see is that the element that wasn't
expandable before is now expandable
because it has a pseudo element on it
and then you can style it any way that
you want you can do normal declarations
with it put a width and a height and the
color and a position on it like you can
move it around the page and do what you
want with it
so I find that these are really powerful
and you can use these in conjunction
with hover States and like checked and
focus and all of those so that you can
really start to build a beautiful system
where things move and and respond
so just reiterate we want to be
inclusive for our entire user base
especially for people using screen
readers and for people who are using
keyboard navigation so what you don't
want to do is if you're if you have like
a menu hamburger icon you don't want to
place open menu inside of your
pseudo-element because that's not gonna
be read otherwise they're really well
supported so you can't put inputs on or
you can't put before-and-after elements
on inputs so Drupal gives you this very
handy wrapper around all of your form
fields
I recommend placing your pseudo elements
on that that's what I do it works pretty
well the other thing is that if you use
REM units and Internet Explorer it's not
going to read them so with pseudo
elements I try to use pixel or even
viewport height unit sometimes so you
have full control over these elements
just like anything else that you would
in the Dom so it transitions and
animations this is where all of these
student elements really come into play
you can do a lot with these you can also
apply transitions and animations to
other elements within the dom text links
images you have full control of your
site and all of the styles that are
going into this work so if I can get
this to play
all right so this is a site that we have
an active development right now but you
can see here we have a hamburger menu or
performing some transitions on this and
all of this is done with a simple class
change so we're setting a click event in
JavaScript and then altering the class
on this button and then actually all of
these lines are pseudo elements and the
and the clothes menu is a span within
that that button that we created but you
can see there's there's a little bit of
motion from the clothes menu it kind of
slides to the left as the opacity fades
in the the hamburger lines are opening
and collapsing onto themselves and these
are all based off of top placement and
left-right placement using relative
positioning
and so this is a simpler example
let's get that one but buttons
oftentimes you'll want to change the
background color when you're hovering
over a button and it's really simple to
create a gradual transition for that
with again one line of CSS so first up
we're gonna talk about keyframes because
there are a couple different ways that
you can animate that first animation is
done using keyframes and what you can do
with this is set up either repeating
actions or complicated actions that you
want to perform all at once
so using keyframes you're gonna set up
essentially a map of what you want to
happen during the animation first and so
that's what we're the at keyframes
syntax comes into play and then the
percents here are the the time in the
animation which you'll set the actual oh
I want this to be two seconds long I
want this to be ten seconds long later
on but this is saying at the very start
of the animation which is zero percent I
want it to start like this and at the
end of the animation at 100 percent I
want it to end like this so usually when
I find that I'm doing is I'm using the
50 percent mark to set the in-between
state like if I want to hover over a
button and have it go like Boop and go
up a little bit and then come back down
so that it rests into its natural state
I do that with the the 50 percent mark
so you have some control over what's
going in here when you actually go in to
apply you're going to add your animation
this is the long hand just to go through
the individual aspects here but you can
set your animation name so you can see I
named my keyframes bounce and so then
I'm just
Halling bounce later on and then I'm
setting my duration which is usually in
seconds a lot of these I use short spans
of time and then iteration count is how
many times you want it to repeat the
direction I actually don't use that very
often but you could have it go it in one
direction then reverse and timing
function is really helpful here as well
because if you have in JavaScript if you
want to have something move across the
page and have a little bit of
personality to it you might want it to
follow a cubic Bezier curve this is
something that I go to generators to
build I don't try to figure this out on
my own it's complicated math I don't
want to do math at work I'm a developer
not a mathematician so I go and I find
that somewhere else but there are some
really easy shortcuts that you can use
as well like ease in ease out and linear
and animation delay is really helpful if
you want something to happen a little
bit later and this is helpful if you're
doing step two animations if you have
something going on first and that's
going to take four seconds and you want
your second animation to happen a little
bit later you can set your animation
delay to be four seconds so that happens
after on the same element and then the
shorthand for this is down here at the
bottom where you can just say animation
and then write out all the things that
you want to happen so the really simple
way of using keyframes is just to say
animation and then call your animation
name and set a time to it that's all you
need is the name and the time
so next up is transitions these are a
bit simpler than keyframes I use these
on almost everything but I use them for
really simple subtle things most of
times for for button background color
changes or for link text color changes
or you can use this on borders if you
want to change your inputs to have a
brighter color on focus for example you
could set a transition on the border
color so that it transitions gradually
so here you can see this is the the full
syntax you can include all of these
different settings on your class but all
you really need again is the property
that you're changing and how long you
want it to take so what I usually set
this on is say button hover or on input
focus you can do this on a full div if
you have an image that has a color
overlay on top of it and you want to
hover over it and have that color
overlay fade to opacity zero for example
you can set this on that div and it'll
gradually transition for you instead of
just clicking over so again more ways to
get around JavaScript more ways to
create beautiful animations
again these are very similar to the
keyframe settings CSS doesn't like to be
complicated so these are the tools that
you have at your distance and so what I
would caution against is doing this too
much again I say that I use this
everywhere I do but they're subtle so if
you have a button that goes from navy
blue to light blue this would be a nice
way to add a transition but if you have
something and you're trying to make it
zoom across the page it might be a
little distracting a little jarring for
your users so it's important to think
about okay if I was coming to this site
and I was looking for information would
I find this distracting and just kind of
really yourself back in a little bit
have conversations with your design team
about it to figure out how much you
actually want to put into the site so
that's why oftentimes these go into
those those more subtle places where it
makes your site feel a little more
polished and just beautiful and it's
that you're gonna see qua that you just
can't get without it
so the real tricky one here is the the
older browsers not supporting transition
animations on before-and-after elements
it's not really a huge deal because the
the element will still move it'll still
do exactly what you're telling it to it
just won't have that that nice
transition so this is Photoshop for your
website if you are familiar with using
Photoshop filters like overlay or
saturation color those kinds of fades on
top of images or text that's what blend
modes are gonna do for you online as
well so in case my video doesn't run on
this one I have a backup so you can see
here we've got just a plain div with a
blue background and some white text and
then there's a photo behind it and I
believe this is the MLK speech if we
apply transition elements which is not
playing again but for example this is a
hard light filter that we're placing on
this div and you can see through the div
a little bit now because it's trying to
blend with the thing that's behind it
and then screen does the opposite effect
where it's actually lightening
everything behind it and itself so you
can use this throughout your your site
that's using mixed blend mode we also
have background blend mode background
blend mode blends the background color
and the background image on an
individual div with each other whereas
mix blend mode blends two divs that are
on top of each other with each other
so the the list is long and amazing of
the the types of blend modes you can use
but I've listed them all here you never
know which one's gonna be right until
you try it to be completely honest or at
least I don't
so again testing is key here if you have
one of these blend modes that does not
apply in a certain browser it'll just
fall back to being a regular diff he'll
just do its its normal thing so the the
key is to place the content on top make
sure that it's always visible if this
doesn't apply but the the syntax is
really simple you just say mix blend
mode overlay and background blend mode
exclusion and so the the only thing to
really remember here is that background
blend mode needs to be separate from
your other background declaration it
doesn't fit into the shorthand syntax so
again accessibility you guys let's be
careful with the kinds of images that
we're blending with the kinds of divs
that we're blending with each other you
know perform some user testing to make
sure that the color contrast is working
well a lot of people have issues with
even the the different colors reacting
to each other so this is worth testing
with an accessibility tester if you
don't have somebody who does that at
your company or organization there are a
lot of people who will do this ad hoc
and help you and there are a lot of
trainings that you can go to there are
also a number of accessibility trains
going on at Drupal con if you want to
learn a little bit more about that
and this one is the the trickiest for a
browser support because this is one of
the more bleeding edge elements so
you're not gonna get any ie
support whatsoever for this that's okay
it'll just look normal
and there are some some browser hacks
that you can do to make us perform a
little bit better and some of those
older browsers but I find that it's
better to make sure that your fallback
is graceful rather than trying to force
it in there because then you're doing
more work and we don't want to do more
work we wanted less work and lastly
we've got textured typography I'm doing
well on time okay so textured typography
essentially is if you are used to using
pngs for your text let's not do that
anymore you can use HTML text with
textures you can apply solid textures
and textures with transparency to text
and it's gonna look beautiful because I
have an example tada this is HTML text
we our parks is I think a paragraph tag
might be an h2 but this is an SVG with
the tree-ring pattern that is then being
placed on top of real HTML text so this
falls back in older browsers to just be
white there's no texture there and the
way that I did that is using a selector
through moderniser to make sure that I
had that support this one is a little
bit more difficult to see but there's a
little speckled texture happening on
this navy blue text this is an opaque
texture the opaque textures have better
support than the transparent textures
but it's going to be a similar workflow
for you
so you can see here that there's a
little bit of a difference between
transparency and solid texture so with
solid texture what you're doing is you
are applying background clip text to a
background image on the text which means
that your fill color in Firefox has to
be transparent or else you're not going
to see your texture so on text that is
navy blue if you set the color to be
navy blue it's just gonna be navy blue
on top of your background image so again
being really careful about which
browsers you're applying this in will
save you some heartache as we do with
transparency I like to set my fill color
on these ones to be a very very very
soft same color of the texture that I'm
applying just that I can see the outline
in case it's not applying right it's a
helpful testing tip and usually people
won't be able to see it because the
texture is a higher contrast so again
you're just setting a background image
in this case it's an SVG image and then
we're setting background clip text again
so really the the important thing here
aside from testing your browsers is to
make sure that you don't have really
strict requirements for those fall backs
again this goes back to proposal
language and contracts and talking to
stakeholders to make sure that they
understand what's going on with the site
and and that you're writing the site to
be future forward and not backwards
facing so talking about how it's going
to be a solid piece of text in an older
browser
so the last bit here the at not asterisk
route this is one that I've used a few
times this comes from browser hacks com
it's essentially a browser specific
selector that will help you frame this
CSS so that it's only in the one browser
without having to use modernizr to grab
a class there are similar browser hacks
for all of these different techniques
and you can find those on on browser
hacks com use these lightly you know you
don't want to use this across your
entire site because if a new version of
a browser comes out and all of a sudden
your text is broken you don't want to
have to go through 50 different
declarations to remove them all so what
I recommend is using a sass mixin to set
these styles and that way if you do get
an update you can apply the update
statewide all right so this week is all
about Drupal I know this is only about
CSS but this week is about drupal and as
part of the drupal community it's really
important for us to give back if you can
attend the contribution sprints on
friday i highly recommend you do it it's
a great way to make friends it's a great
way to see the people that you've been
hanging out with all week
and it's also a way to give back to the
tool that you're using everyday and then
a little plug for our local con Drupal
gov con will be this year August 22nd to
24th at the NIH and Bethesda is just a
little bit north of Washington DC and
it's entirely free registration is
limited so make sure that you sign up
early if you want to come and we're also
accepting session submissions if you'd
like to speak so I have all of my main
references here to go to these sites the
slides are up and these are linked so
you can just follow the links straight
through to the sites
if you want to tweet at me my handle is
at AC find and I'm happy to answer any
of your questions now
yeah would you mind using the the
microphone actually so that we can get
it recorded Thank You Karl I know when
going through and using blend modes when
it comes down to colors that at least
from Photoshop there were click keyboard
commands you could go and tap through a
lot is there anything available or even
remotely comparable for web tools right
now to do this chrome inspector is
really helpful when I'm setting blend
modes for example if you tab over to the
where you're actually setting the the
style you can keyboard down with the
arrows and it will give you a list of
all of the applicable filters and so
that's how I really quickly check
between like overlay and screen and all
those to make sure I'm getting the right
effect all right I'll try that thanks
any other questions that I can answer
for you alright thanks you guys have a
great time
[Applause]